you ought to be happy where you are
working and I always worry about people
who say you know I'm I'm going to do
this for 10 years I really don't like it
very well and then I'll do 10 more years
of this I mean that's a little like
saving up sex for your old age I
mean not not a very good
idea when I started
Microsoft I didn't think of it as all
that risky you've always got a job with
me
Bill and the only the thing that was
scary to me wasn't quitting and starting
the company was when I started hiring my
friends and they expected to be paid
uh Buffett and Gates on success was made
possible by the Floyd and Dolores Jones
Foundation supporting efforts to enhance
public education and a better
understanding of business and investing
in the American economy
[Music]
this program is brought to you by the
NASDAQ stock market timely investment
information is available at nasdaq.com
and
by the New York Stock
Exchange the world puts its stock in US
[Music]
each spring in Omaha Nebraska thousands
of investors gather from around the
world how long does it take to get over
here from Paris
France 10 hours for
Sweden and roughly uh it's a day flight
a lot of people it reminds me of New
York a lot of
people they come for the annual
shareholders meeting of an investment
company birkshire Hathaway many come
just for a chance to meet berkshire's
legendary chairman Warren Buffett
obviously when the stock goes up a lot
it it it creates interest and during the
past four decades Buffett's uncanny
success in picking stocks has made big
money for Burkshire shareholders
including Buffett himself his net worth
is estimated at more than $30
billion one highlight of the annual
meeting is birkshire Hathaway day at an
Omaha Royals baseball game Buffett
throws out the first
piit books analyzing Buffett's
investment philosophy have acclaimed him
the world's greatest investor but he's
made his fortune in companies welln to
all companies such as Coca-Cola Gillette
and Dairy Queen he avoids anything
Hightech so how long have you been using
a the computer yet one of Buffett's good
friends is Bill Gates Microsoft's
co-founder and CEO is 26
years his enormous success has come from
a technological Revolution that he has
done much to Pioneer and popularize
learning what did you learn about Gates
started Microsoft with his high school
friend Paul Allen when Gates was still
in his teens their investment
$1,500 ski jumping the ski jumping
that's pretty exciting isn't it today
Microsoft's annual sales exceed $14
billion it is the world's leading
developer of software for the personal
computer and Gates is the PC's Globe
trotting evangelist celebrating its many
benefits am I going to have time to get
everybody okay success has made Bill
Gates the world's wealthiest and perhaps
most famous
entrepreneur it also has made Microsoft
a target of controversy the popularity
of its Windows software has brought
legal challenges from government
antitrust Regulators they've tried to
limit Microsoft's expansion into new
Fields such as the
Bill Gates and Warren Buffett share a
Restless curiosity and fascination with
the future together in the spring of
1998 they came to the campus of the
University of Washington in Seattle they
came to share their experience and their
combined wisdom in conversation with
students from the University's business
school young people overflowed the
Student Union Auditorium for an
extraordinary conversation with two of
the most successful Business Leaders of
our time proceedings so please join me
in giving a University of Washington
Business School welcome to Bill Gates
and to Warren Buffett
[Applause]
[Music]
well I thought I ought to uh start this
off by announcing that bill and I uh
have a small bet as to who would get the
mo most Applause
and I suggested that I bet my house
against his but
uh but we settled on a small sum but
evidently it isn't so small to bill
because because just before we came out
he gave me this Nebraska Corn osar shirt
to wear and he puts on this purple
shirt we're going to U we're going to
answer your questions whatever you want
to talk about is is fine and we uh we
don't want any softballs and I I thought
by wearing this cornos shirt that I
could guarantee hard balls right in my
head when we went to the game last year
about halfway through the first quarter
Bill said what's that big end stand for
on those guys of yours I said Bill I
said what the hell I said it's
knowledge we all agree on that Nebraska
well they've asked us to start out
talking uh with the two of us uh uh on
one question but then it's going to be
your questions and we're going we're
going to just have you line up behind
the microphones and we'll go back and
forth uh they they did ask that we might
to start off with talking about uh sort
of what got us here and uh uh it's
pretty simple in my case it it's it's
not IQ I'm sure you'll all be glad to
hear that the but everybody in this room
has more IQ than they need to do my job
the U the big thing is rationality and
in other words you know I always look at
IQ and and talent is sort of
representing the uh the horsepower of
the motor but then in terms of the
output the efficiency which which the
motor works that depends on rationality
because a lot of people start out with
400 horsepower motors and get 100
horsepower of output and it's way better
to have a 200 horsepower motor and get
it all into output and and so why do why
do smart people do things that interfere
with really getting the the the output
they're entitled to and it's uh it gets
into the habits into character and
temperament and it really gets into
behaving in a rational manner it's and
not letting not getting in your own way
as I say every everybody here has the
ability absolutely to do anything I do
and and much Beyond and and some of you
will and some of you won't but it it it
it will the ones that won't it will be
because be because uh uh you get in your
own way it won't because the the world
doesn't allow you to it it will be
because you don't allow yourself to so I
have one little suggestion for you pick
out the person in the class that you
admire the most and then write down why
you admire them put down a list of
qualities uh you're not to name yourself
in
this and uh and then put down the the
one uh uh that frankly you could stand
the least in the whole group and put the
put down the qualities that U that uh uh
turn you off in that person and look at
that list and and you won't find it's a
bunch of things like throwing a football
70 yards or you know or anything of the
sort the qualities of the first one that
you admire are qualities that that uh
you with a little practice uh can make
your own and which if practice will
become habit forming the chains of habit
are too light to be felt until they're
too heavy to be broken I mean my age I
can't change any of my habits I mean I'm
stuck but at your age you know you will
have the habits 20 years from now that
you decide to put into practice today so
I just suggest that that you you look at
the habits you admire in others or the
behavior you admire in others and and
make those your own uh habits and you
look at at what you really find uh uh
somewhat reprehensible in others and
just decide you know those are things
you're not going to do Ben Franklin did
that a few hundred years ago and it
still works today and if if you do that
uh you'll find that uh you convert all
your horsepower into output so with that
sermon I'll let Bill give you another
one and then we'll get into your
question well I think Warren's
absolutely right about habit um I was
lucky enough when I was quite young to
have an exposure to computers which were
um very expensive and and kind of
limitated and limited in what they could
do but but still fascinating and some
friends and I really talked about that
and decided that uh they they would
change because of a miracle technology
of of chips into something that
everybody could take advantage of and we
really thought writing software was a
neat thing we hired our friends who
wrote software thought about uh what the
potentials were and really didn't see
any limit and so that that vision of of
getting our friends together uh getting
them to work as a team uh really seeing
uh what kind of tool this could be a
tool of of what uh we talked about is
the information age where the key thing
is magnifying your brain power instead
of of just your muscle power and by
pursuing that with a pretty incredible
focus and being there at the very very
beginning of the industry uh we were
able to build a company that has uh
played a very Central role in what's
been a pretty big revolution now
fortunately uh the revolution is still
at the beginning it was 23 years ago
when we started the company but there's
no doubt that taking the habits we
formed and sticking with those uh which
would be hard to change the next 23
years are going to give us a lot more
potential and maybe even get us pretty
close to that original Vision which was
a a computer on every desk and in every
home and that's a a fun fun thing to be
involved
with okay fire away I was wondering how
you define success
personally well I can certainly define
happiness because that's what that's
what I am I mean I and if that if
that I mean I get to do what I like to
do every single day of the year and I
get to do it with people I like and I
get to the I get to I don't have to
associate with anybody causes my stomach
to churn at uh uh and uh the only thing
in my job I don't like and this only
happens about every three or four years
occasionally I have to fire somebody and
I don't like that's the only thing other
than I I tap dance to work and I get
down there and I think I'm supposed to
lie on my back and paint the ceiling you
know or something like Micha angel I
mean that's the way I feel and I and and
it it it it doesn't diminish it it's
it's tremendous fun so uh you know if uh
uh they say that uh uh success is uh uh
getting what you want and happiness is
wanting what you get well I don't know
which one applies in this case but I I
do know that I I wouldn't be doing
anything else I mean that uh uh I do
advise you you know when you go out to
work go go to work for an organization
that you admire people you admire
because it'll it'll it'll turn you on
and and and uh uh you ought to be happy
where you are working and I always worry
about people who say you know I'm I'm
going to do this for 10 years I really
don't like it very well then I'll do 10
more years of this and I mean that's a
little like saving up sex for your old
age I
mean not not a very good
idea so get right recommend that get
right get right in get right into what
you enjoy you know and
and and you'll be successful at it you
really will I mean you won't be able to
miss and uh um you know that's uh uh
I don't regard what I do as the most
important thing in the world at all but
it's right for me I mean I happen to be
wired in a certain way that what I do
Works in this if I had to do what you
know Bill does I mean it last about 10
minutes and uh that's true of a lot of
things but I luckily I kind of stumbled
into the thing that I I do best and and
that you know that it's worked out well
bill I think that the key point there is
you've got to enjoy what you do every
day and for me that's working with very
smart people it's working on new
problems you know every time we think
hey we've had a little bit of success
we're pretty careful not to dwell on it
too much because the bar gets raised
people's expectations of the the
products we've always got customer
feedback telling us the machines are too
complicated they're not they're not
natural enough and the the competition
uh the the the breakthroughs the
research make uh the field I'm I'm in I
think the most exciting field there is
there's some other good Fields
biotechnology is a good field because
it's uh changing the world of of
medicine and and health but the computer
industry in particular software you know
I I think uh is the most exciting and I
think I have the the best job in that in
that business don't you think Dair Queen
is more important in the
country you can manage par Queen I I'll
go and buy the Billy bars yeah I'm
counting on it we'll raise the price
when you
come
okay yeah you don't want it you don't
want to get in I I have turned down
business deals that were otherwise
decent deals because I didn't like the
people that I would have to work with I
didn't see any sense pretending it and
to take on to get involved with people
that really cause your stomach to turn
you know I I say it's a lot like
marrying for money that it's it's
probably a bad idea under any
circumstances but it absolutely crazy if
you're already rich right
both of you are innovatives in your
given industry I was wondering what your
definition of innovation
is well I don't I don't do a lot of
innovating in in in what I do I mean I I
my job I really have just two functions
in my job one one is to allocate Capital
which I enjoy doing and uh and the
second one is to have a group of
managers to keep a group of people
people 15 or 20
managers uh enthused about what they do
when they have no Financial need to do
it whatsoever three at least three4 of
the managers we have um are rich Beyond
any possible Financial need and and
therefore my job is to figure out how to
cause them to want to jump out of bed at
6:00 in the morning and and and work
with all of the enthusiasm they did when
they when they were poor and starting
and and if I do those two things they do
the ation but Bill innovates now he can
tell you about it well the technology
business has a lot of twists and turns
and that's why partly why it's such a
fun business is that you know no company
gets to rest on its Laurels you know IBM
was as dominant are more dominant than
any company will ever be in technology
that's just just not going to happen
again and they had the smartest people
and they had all the customer feedback
and yet they missed a few turns in the
road and and so that makes you wake up
every day thinking hm let's try to make
sure today's not the day we miss the
turn in the road uh let's uh you know
find out what's going on in speech
recognition let's go find out what's
going on in artificial intelligence
let's make sure we're hiring in the kind
of uh people who can pull those things
together and make sure we don't uh we
don't get surprised sometimes uh we do
get taken by surprise for example the
internet came
along and we had it sort of as a fifth
or sixth
priority it wasn't like somebody said
internet to me and I said oh I don't
know how to spell that uh I said yeah I
got that on my list I'm okay uh but
there came a point where we realized it
was happening faster and and it was a
much deeper phenomena than it it um had
been recognized in our strategy and so
that was a case where uh as an active
leadership I had to create a sense of
crisis in have a couple months where we
all just threw ideas and sent electronic
mail around went on a bunch of Retreats
and then eventually coales around a few
ideas where we said okay here's how
we're going here's what we're going to
do here's how we're going to measure
ourselves internally and here's what the
world should think here's what we're
going to tell them about what we're
going to do and that kind of Crisis is
likely to come up um every three or four
years or so next time it comes up
remember Yogi barabel when it when you
reach a for fork in the road take
it growing up who were your biggest role
model and what kind of a role did they
play in your success you know I had uh
great parents and both of whom were
involved in uh lots of interesting
activities and would come home and talk
to us about you know the world of of
business or law or politics or the
charitable activities they were involved
in and so that made us uh my myself my
sisters always thought about well what
are we going to do out there uh they had
us as Avid readers and so we uh had
pretty broad interest in Reading uh
scientists were a group that I
gravitated to because this notion that
just you know out of their heads they
came up with neat ideas uh that sort of
fascinated me so quite a quite a bit of
the time I thought I'd be a
mathematician or a scientist it was only
when I got to
Harvard that I started to think of this
uh sort of all absorbing hobby I'd had
computer stuff which I just thought okay
I got to get rid of this and decide to
do something serious I start to realize
you know this is pretty serious and it's
actually more interesting and more
impactful than uh you know going in and
trying to come up with a new theory in
math or or anything else and so I I had
that dilemma for a couple years but
eventually decided that uh uh computer
really was a great a great thing to be
involved with yeah I think you're 100%
on the money and and focusing I I would
instead of calling them Role Models I
call them Heroes actually and and
and I think if you you tell me who your
heroes are I can tell you how you're
going to turn out to quite an extent by
this point in life and and I I I have
been extraordinarily lucky and that none
of my heroes ever let me down I mean I
the ones I came up with uh throughout
their lives I've never felt that I've
been let down in any way with it number
one was my dad and and uh uh had a huge
impression on me um my wife who is hero
is one of my heroes I mean she is uh you
know in terms of of she's taught me a
tremendous amount and and and uh never
seen anybody any better with human
beings than she is and uh uh you can you
know Yogi Bear again said you can you
can observe a lot just by watching
and I uh you know I I watched my dad and
I I've watched her and uh I had a
professor Ben Graham uh back at Columbia
and had a huge impact on me so I have
been lucky and that I've had terrific
Heroes and they they have let me down
and and uh uh that that takes you a long
long way I I've gone through one or two
periods where that we're kind of tough
in life but not I mean every everybody's
had had that but but having the right
Heroes will take you right through
it the internet exposes us to vast
amounts of information and in particular
children are being exposed to more and
more complex issues at very young ages
yourself being a father Mr Gates I was
wondering if you had any comments on the
access now to information and how do we
handle
that definitely the
internet has every kind of in
information you can imagine all the the
worst things and best things that people
are interested in are out there in uh
great great
quantity and so there there's a decision
a parent has in terms of do you let your
kid go out onto the internet one one
great thing about the internet is if you
set it up the right way there's a log of
exactly what the person's gone and
looked at and so you know you have to
decide up to what age do you think it's
legitimate uh that you have access to
see where they're going and what they're
interested in and personally I'd rather
see what my kid is interested in and
talk to them about it than try and block
alog together them ever learning
anything about it because some day in
their life uh whether it's a you know a
magazine or a friend or a terminal that
I don't I don't control if they're
curious about something
um they're they're going to find out
about it and you know my so my my theory
is not that you know my child to be okay
as long as they don't hear about things
you want to have the full experience and
uh uh but I I think uh on the whole the
fact that a kid has this tool to be
curious about all these topics that's
got to be a fantastic
thing I can't improve on that I I but I
am I just got to the age where Bill lets
me watch the internet alone
so I've been trying that that's a good
story I you know I've been trying to
evangelize personal computers to Warren
ever since we met which is uh over about
seven years ago now and uh it was
amazing you know I talked about stock
quotes and spreadsheets and all these
things and in the end it wasn't uh my uh
talking at all that got him on it was
the ability to play bridge with his
friends and uh now he's he's
incredible he's an addict yeah do you
feel that technology has made businesses
more efficient to the point where you
can pay more for them well it I I'm sure
technology has made more efficient and
and if if I thought otherwise I would
I'd be afraid to say so with Bill
sitting next to me
but a lot of things in business in
including uh maybe much of Technology
really amounts has the same effect as if
you went to a parade and the band
started coming down the street and all
of a sudden you stood up on tiptoe I
mean in another 30 seconds everybody be
on tiptoe you know it'd be hell on your
legs and you wouldn't be seeing any
better and and there is that aspect to
business that there's a
self-neutralizing aspect now Bill tell
them how much technology you'll make for
no I think it there's definitely a lift
a one-time lift where you go from not
using technology well to using it well
particularly if us companies are doing
that better than their
competitors uh outside the United States
and so you get all this ability to
communicate and so you get global scale
in a lot of businesses that wouldn't
have had it before if you look at the
really big earners in that who are
generating this 20% return on Equity a
lot of them are companies like Koch or
mik Microsoft or boing or GE which are
going to that that worldwide Marketplace
and I know every one of those has been
helped by technology but that that
cannot explain why 10 years from now
they'd be getting that type of return on
Equity there's something uh almost
certainly ephemeral about about current
conditions capitalism tends to be
self-neutralizing in terms of
improvements but that that's marvelous
because it means we've got better
everything than we have otherwise but
the real trick is to stand up on tiptoe
and not have anyone notice it I mean if
you can do that for then you do very
well yeah Bill Warren the world is
becoming a much smaller place both in
technology and in finance how do you see
yourselves as businessmen taking your
businesses globally and how do you view
that individually as a
person well I've got an easier answer so
I I'll let I'll let Bill think while I
get the easy answer we don't do it
directly I mean our two largest
commitments are are K and Gillette and I
co has 80% of their earnings coming from
abroad and it'll be larger in the future
Gillette has 2third of their earnings
coming from abroad and that'll be larger
in the future so they are participating
in in a worldwide Improvement in in in
living and they'll continue to
participate so we do it by piggybacking
them and I can sit in Omaha you know and
and let and let Doug ivester at Coke fly
all over the world and do a tremendous
job doing it bill has to get out there
and and and do it for Microsoft and I'll
let him tell you
how one great thing about our business
is it is it is global uh that what do
you need in a spreadsheet about the same
thing in Korea and Egypt as you need in
the United States and the PC standard is
a global standard we have to do some
adaptation for the local languages and
that's a fun part of our business
understanding bidirectional languages
and the large uh alphabets that you have
in uh Chinese Japanese and Korean and
over the years we've gotten very very
good at that in fact our market share is
much higher outside the United States
than it is inside the United States
because it's relatively hard to set up
subsidiaries understand local uh
conditions local distribution and
relationships and so since most of our
competitors are in the US and aren't as
good at doing international business we
Thrive uh even better in these other
countries most of our growth will come
from outside the United States the
United States will get to the point
where it's largely a replacement Market
most homes and business desktops will
have PCS now that doesn't mean they
won't replace them that they won't want
better software that can see listen and
learn but outside the US we still have
that that early slope phenomena so it's
very much a global global business when
you think about it many of you are
probably too young to remember with
Clarity anyway 15 years ago that this
country almost had an inferiority
complex about its ability to comp
compete in the world and and you know
and with software and and and and and
the whole uh uh development of the
computer uh now the rest of the world is
looking to us and you know and and you
know vill has vill has played a big part
in that I mean he has he has contributed
in a major way to a change in our
attitude about this country and and the
world's attitude about this
country so what impelled you to make a
trip together to China in 1995 and uh
what's your perception before and after
the trip and uh most next question is
that uh what has that trip affected your
um Global business decision in that
region
since well we went to China for a lot of
reasons partly to relax and and have fun
uh we found a few McDonald's there just
so we didn't didn't feel too uh away
from home now it was also exciting to go
and see all the changes taking place I
mean it's so
amazing uh what what's going on there
and we saw different parts of the
country got to see some of the leaders
uh it's a market that uh you know we
Microsoft had already been investing a
lot and we've up that quite a bit since
then although about three million
computers get sold every year in in
China people don't pay for the software
uh and
um they they will though
uh it's sort of a as long as they're
going to steal that we want them to
steal ours uh they sort of sort of get
addicted and then we somehow figure out
how to how to collect sometime in the
next uh in the next decade so you know
it's a great great place to be involved
in and it was a lot of fun which was I
guess the the key goal my family was
amazed I went I i' never traveled more
than maybe you know the outer reaches of
the county in Nebraska and and and and
uh I I just went and had a a a terrific
time and and also confirmed my feeling
that there were going to be a lot of
Coca-Cola sold there in the
future I told everybody over there that
acted as an aphrodiziac I don't
know as two of the most successful
business people in the country what role
do you see for yourselves in giving back
to your respective communities and how
do you use your influence to get others
to give back as well
well I think we both have a quite a
similar philosophy on that that uh I
know in my my own case uh uh that
99% plus will go back to society and
that'll actually count everything that
my family and I have have lived on
during our entire lifetimes but just
because that uh uh we've been treated
extraordinary well well by Society you
know I'm lucky Bill said if I've born a
long time ago i' have been some animals
lunch you know I
mean I don't run very fast you know I'm
but but I I'm wired in a particular way
that in a market economy big capitalist
economy lots of action uh I I'm I'm I'm
well adapted for that I'm not adapted
for pro football I'm not adapted for
Bolin playing there I just I happen to
be in something that pays off huge in
the society and basically I I get the
fun of playing around with that while I
live but it it will all go back to to
society and and uh uh I think it would
be I think it'd be wrong to be to be
otherwise frankly if I'd been dropped
down in uh you know in in in uh some
remote country or almost any other place
in the world I wouldn't have been worth
a damn I mean I I I am here because of a
tremendous society that surrounds me and
and the fact that I happen to be well
adapted to a certain part of it and so
it all it's all going to go back to
society and I know Bill feels very
similar no I think that's
a great philosophy not to mention the
fact that uh passing along lots of money
can be a bad thing for the people who uh
receive it they might not think so at
times but uh I've never put it to a
vote I don't I really don't think it's I
don't think it's right that the uh
frankly I don't think it's right that
the quarterback of the Nebraska football
team next year should be the eldest son
of the quarterback of 22 years ago nor
do I think that our Olympic team
uh in 2000 should be chosen as to be
from the same family that was on the
Olympic team in all the respective
Sports in 1976 I mean we believe in the
meritocracy when it comes to Athletics
and all kinds of things now why not have
a meritocracy in in in in terms of what
you go out into the world with in terms
of the productive Goods let let let let
the let the resources flow to those who
use them best but then I think they
ought to give them back to society
primarily when they get through I I do
not believe in a divine right of the
womb I mean I do not think that you you
know that if you select the right womb
that you're entitled to do nothing the
rest of your life it doesn't make any
[Applause]
[Music]
sense hi there's been a lot of
discussion about how the information age
is revolutionizing society and I would
like to um get your opinion about which
countries and industries and companies
are best prepared to take advantage of
these changes and what factors would
account best for their
success maybe I'll I'll start with that
if you look at what's happened in
personal computers or what's happened in
business in general in terms of how we
allocate capital and let labor move
around the United States is has emerged
in a very strong position and so the the
first beneficiary of of all this
information technology will be the
United States uh there are a few other
areas like Singapore Hong Kong the
Scandinavian countries where they're
adopting the technology at basically the
same rate that we are there's a few
countries that even relative to their
level of income are going after the
technology because they believe so much
in education in Korea and uh many parts
of China we see incredible penetration
of personal computers even at very low
income levels because they basically
decided it's a tool to help their kids
uh have access to information and and to
get ahead uh the whole world is going to
benefit in a big way you know the
there'll be this shift where instead of
your income level mainly being derived
by what country you're in it'll be
derived by what your education level is
so today a PhD in India doesn't make
nearly as much as a PhD in the United
States well as you get the internet
allowing services and advice
to be transported as efficiently as
goods are being transported uh through
shipping and all all those things then
you'll get essentially a open market
bidding for that engineer in India
versus the engineer here in the United
States and that benefits everyone
because you're taking better advantage
of those resources and and uh people are
better off so there'll be the developed
countries will get the early benefit
from these things in the long run the
people who are lucky enough to get a
good education in developing countries
will actually get an absolute the
biggest Boost from all these things that
go on it it I didn't get it at first but
it it's huge and it it it will change
the world the technological revolution
in in in in in dramatic ways and and and
quick quickly uh ironically our approach
to that is is is just the opposite of
bills but that his his is the right one
for the world is the right one for me uh
I I look for
businesses that where I think I can see
what they're going to look like in 10 or
15 or 20 years we don't own any but if
you take uh uh Wrigley's chewing gum I I
don't think the internet's going to
affect how people chew gum you know and
Bill Bill probably does I
mean but but I I don't think it's going
to affect the fact that that that coke
will be the the drink of preference and
will gain in per capita consumption
around the world I don't think it'll
change that whether people shave or how
they shave or the fact that they like a
better better uh shaving system as the
Mach 3 is going to be very shortly on my
dad so I we are looking for the very
predictable and you won't find the very
predictable in what build us you'll find
the more exciting things the things are
going to change society more and and so
I have a little different opinion I as a
as a member of society I applaud what
he's doing and as a as a an investor I
keep a wary eye on it uh uh and that's
uh you know it's it's a different
approach to investing most people think
of that all as opportunity and it has
been opportunity every Internet stock
has gone crazy here in recent months but
I don't know how to look at one or the
other and and and and tell the winners
yeah I I this is an area I agree
strongly with Warren on I think the
multiples of technology stocks should be
quite a bit lower than the multiples of
stocks like Coke and Gillette because we
are subject to complete change in the
rules you know I know very well that in
the next 10 years if Microsoft's still a
leader there will have been three at
least three crises that we will have had
to really prove our uh our excellence in
uh I accidentally once when we were on a
panel with the CEO of coke I said
something like uh I couldn't run my
business when I get to be 60 because
it's such a hard business not like
Coke and I I offended him uh without
meaning without meaning to you won't
offend me I want to be in a business I
can run when I'm 100 because I plan to
do
it I'm going to retire about 5 years
after I
die
maybe starting a new company is very
risky how do you determine when is the
best opportunity to start a new company
and how can you get people to support
you well it when I started
Microsoft I didn't think of it as all
that risky I I mean I was so excited
about what we were doing it's true I
could have gone bankrupt uh but you know
I had a set of skills that were highly
employable and in fact my parents were
still willing to let me go back to
Harvard and finish my education if I
wanted to you've always got a job with
Mayville and the only the thing that was
scary to me wasn't quitting and starting
the company it was when I started hiring
my friends and they expected to be paid
uh
and and then we had customers who went
bankrupt customers that I'd counted on
to come through and so then I got this
incredibly conservative approach that I
wanted to have enough money in the bank
to pay a Year's worth of payroll uh even
if we didn't get any any payments coming
in and I'm almost uh true to that the
whole time we have about 10 billion now
which is is pretty much enough for the
next year
uh anyway you know I if you're going to
start a company it takes so much energy
that you know you it better overcome
your your feeling of risk I don't think
that you necessarily if you're going to
start a company should do it at the
start of your career I think there's a
lot to be said for working for a company
learning how they do things you know if
you're young it's hard to go lease
premises they they made that hard for me
you couldn't rent a car uh when you were
uh uh under 25 at the time so I was
always taking taxis to go see customers
um
and uh the people would you know people
say well we're going to go have a
discussion in the bar well I couldn't go
to the bar
uh and but you know that's fun because
I'll tell you when people are first
skeptical and they think oh this kid
doesn't know anything then when you show
them you've really got a good product
and you know something they actually
tend to go overboard and they think whoa
you know they know a lot uh let's really
do an inedible amount with these people
so our youth at least in this country uh
was a a huge asset for us once we
reached a a certain threshold it is hard
it's hard to hire old older people um
because they'll be a little bit
conservative about whether they should
come and and take the risk and it took
three or four years before we could go
out into the normal sort of employment
pool but those those PRS that come a
starting the firm you better think of
those as as part of the the pleasure
part of the the the challenge that that
is part of the the
excitement I was curious what each of
you felt was the best business decision
You' made um throughout your career the
best what business
decision
uh I think just getting in jumping in
the pool basically I mean I I I i' I
I've always enjoyed what I've done and
and and a few things have worked out
very well and and the nice thing about
the investment business is is that you
don't need very many you'll you'll see
plenty of times when you get chances to
do things that just shout at you and the
the thing you have to do is is when that
happens you have to take a big swing I
mean there is that is no time to be
reading a book on the theory of
diversification Ian I mean that is a
time to put you put very sign when you
find something that where you know the
business that's within your circle of
competence you understand it The Price
is Right the people are right then you
know you take your you take your out of
your mouth and you Barrel
in we were talking at breakfast this
morning about uh of all Warren's
Investments decisions which was the
worst decision which it's amazing and
they're tough to find because he uh he's
you know the track Rec it's unbelievable
uh but we I think decided that by uh
some Metric the buying the company that
he his company is named after was
probably the worst investment decision
uh that's true I mean we went into a
terrible business because it was cheap
and it's what I referred to as the the
used cigar butt approach to investing
you know that you see this cigar butt
down there it's soggy you know it's
terrible but there is one puff in it and
it's free
and and that's what birkshire was when
we bought it I mean it was selling below
working capital actually buying
birkshire halfway buying control of it
was probably the biggest single bad
decision that I've made and then the I I
made all kinds of decisions that have
cost us billions of dollars but they've
been they've been mistakes of omission
rather than commission I mean there were
businesses that we knew enough to buy a
lot of I don't worry about not buying
Microsoft because I I I I didn't
understand that business I don't didn't
understand Intel but there were
businesses that I did understand Fanny
May was one I mean I made a decision to
buy it and I just I didn't execute and
we would have made many billions of
dollars on something that was within my
circle of competence and I didn't do it
and you don't see that accounting
conventional accounting doesn't record
that but believe me it
happened in in my case I'd say my best
business decisions really have to do
with uh picking people you know deciding
to go into partnership with Paul Allen
uh is is probably at the top of the list
and then uh
subsequently uh hiring a friend Steve
Balmer and having somebody who you
totally trust who who's totally
committed who shares your vision and yet
has a a little bit different set of
skills and also acts as a check on you
you know some of the ideas you come up
with you run by them because you know
they're going to say hey wait a minute
uh you know have you thought about this
and that and just you know the the
benefit of sparking off of somebody
who's who's got that kind of Brilliance
it's not only made it fun but it's
really led to a lot of success so
picking picking a partner is is crucial
yeah and I've had a partner like that
Charlie Munger for a lot of years and
and it it does for me exactly what what
bill was talking about Charlie and you
have to calibrate with Charlie though
because Charlie says everything I do is
dumb but but if he says it's really dumb
then I know it is but if he just says
it's dumb I take that as a affirmative
vote go ahead um if you can change one
thing in your life what would it be and
why my age
uh you know I I never look back I I I
just don't I don't worry about anything
I mean I uh I uh so I consider myself
unbelievably lucky so the idea of saying
I could have even been a little luckier
if this or that had happened you know I
mean you know I could have been a lot
better looking or I could have been a
better athlete or all that stuff but so
what you know I you play the hand you
get you play it as well as you can and
and you're thankful if you're lucky
enough
the odds were when I was born the odds
were over 50 to one against me being
born in the United States I mean I had a
two% probability you know if I had KNN
that I might have given up and not come
out I mean but but here it was you know
I was lucky enough to be born here and I
was lucky enough to have two terrific
parents and
they they raised the the three kids in a
way that that helped me enormously uh in
life so I mean when you got all that
going for I I just don't think you look
back and and think about anything that
could be changed better I'm thankful
isn't there at least one Bridge hand you
would have played differently well I
have a partner who says I should have
played every bridge hand differently I
asked her one time I said how should I
play that hand and she said under an
assumed
name I I
think the the key resource you have to
deal with is your time and how you spend
time and I'm pretty rigorous at looking
back each year I even get uh my friend
Steve Balmer to come in and look at my
schedule and criticize hey you you
didn't really need to spend time on this
or that and uh that's pretty useful
because you if I can get more time to
sit down with the engineers if I can get
more time to get out with some customers
those are the things I just love to do
and you know it it just gets me excited
it clears my mind and and so you know
I'm always trying to make sure that that
uh I'm only doing the things that are
important hypothetically if you were to
lose everything today keep everything in
the past but right now starting fresh
and you could only keep three things in
your life tangible or intangible what
three would those
be well I'm not sure how you define the
three I mean I
I you know you'd like to know everything
that you now know I mean because that
the what
what essentially the things I've applied
in the past are going to be applicable
in the future uh this may s if I if I
lost it all without losing any any money
of any other
people it wouldn't bother me a lot if if
I if I took other people down with me it
would kill me you I mean you know that
that is the one thing that would just
that that would destroy you because I
just I wouldn't able I I I'm not sure
I'd recover from that but if it was just
my money it wouldn't make any difference
at all because I keep living about the
same have to give up the plane give
you but I mean I I eat the I eat the
same way everybody in this room eats you
know he eats a lot worse than you guys
too well depends on you to find worse
but I think you're right and you can get
I mean in terms of medical care or
anything I there is virtually there's
very little difference in how how the
people in this room live now and are
going to live in the next 10 years in
the way the way I do so I I wouldn't
miss anything I mean I don't have I I
would like to keep playing the game
because I enjoy it so if I had the
knowledge that I've had that gotten me
here and I had anything to work with at
all and I could probably talk somebody
into giving me a few bucks to start it I
but I would have a lot of fun playing
the game again I mean it it it it uh it
it might be you know I'm I'm not sure I
want to follow your experiment but I I I
think I I think it'd be just about as
much fun as what I do yeah as long as
people didn't go down with me that would
that would be no fun bill yeah starting
out at small scale again you know it's
got a certain attraction to it uh
but you know I think
uh it's interesting now our our business
is not one
where money makes that much difference
at all uh you in fact somebody was
saying to me recently that know
Microsoft has such a a strong position
in our business and I was saying hey if
you took 30 of the top people and
drafted them over to the other team the
score would change you know very very
quickly first of all Not only would the
30 go the people who like working with
the 30 would go with them and so that
it's not there's not some asset there
it's you know all the products are going
to be obsolete very very rapidly it's
it's the people and their sense of how
to do things and their enjoyment and
working with each other and you know
it'd be a shame to give that up uh but
you know starting another company like
that again I I'd have a blast doing
it in light of public controversy that's
caused a lot of confusion in my mind and
has polarized most of my friends and
Associates and perhaps has caused one or
both of you to lose some sleep I'd like
to ask you to share your perspective of
what purpose or what appropriate role
antitrust legislation should play in
American
Business uh I am no anti anti trust uh
scholar I think that uh that uh well I
met Bill eight years ago and he's and he
was he's a terrific teacher and so he
spent about six or seven hours
explaining his business to me and he
actually I mean Here I Am the world's
biggest dummy on technology but he he
explained it to me pretty darn well and
when I got through when he got through
with it I bought 100 shares of stock
just to keep track of him and I think
that shows two things one is that I've
got an IQ of about
50 and the second is I didn't think he
had any
[Music]
Monopoly well the key goal of
competition law is to protect consumers
and to make sure that new products get
created and and that those products are
very Innovative and you can look in the
economy at different sectors and say you
know where is that happening very well
and where is it it not happening as
rapidly no matter how you score it there
is no doubt that one sector of the
economy would stand out as absolutely
the best and that's the personal
computer industry and so the price of
computing before the PC came along was
going down at a certain rate the PC came
along and now it's gone down at an at an
incredible rate uh the variety and
quality of software has also uh
increased at a phenomenal rate we're
absolutely at the peak of that today the
number of new software companies being
started the number of software jobs the
level of Investments the number going
public I mean it's Way Beyond even what
it was three years ago it's on a a big
uptake um and so consumers are doing
very very well and so it's it is
somewhat of a surprise uh to find
ourselves in an antitrust controversy
and you know thank goodness for the
Judiciary which is an environment where
facts are tested in an appropriate way
and people can see uh you know has the
competition worked in the way it should
has it been beneficial to Consumers and
and there's no doubt in our mind where
that's going to come out um it seems to
a lot of people that uh both the in both
your companies the success is driven by
your enthusiasm and your leadership
skills how do you see your
organizations in the post buffet and
post Gates era and how do you prepare
your companies for that period Well your
your your assumption is wrong because I
I I I will I will keep working until
about five years after I die and I and
and I've given the directors a Ouija
Board and they'll be in
touch but but but but the Ouija the
Ouija board is doesn't work uh we have
outstand maning people that can do what
I do and we've got the people identified
to do that and the board of directors of
Burkshire knows who they are and uh uh
in fact I've got a letter I've already
sent out a letter that tells what should
be done and I've got another letter
that's addressed which will go out at
the time and the and it starts out
yesterday I died and then it just tells
what what what the what the plan for the
company is and it's all it's all taken
care of it's all written I put down at
the bottom of it I put dictated but not
read
yeah my attitude is a lot like Warren I
I uh you know I want to keep doing what
I'm doing for a long long time I think
probably a a decade from now or so uh
even though I'll still want to be
totally involved with Microsoft because
it's my career I will pick somebody else
to be CEO and uh see some hands in the
audience
um that's a a big transition for a
company you know sometimes you find
somebody who does better uh and and
sometimes you don't and no I actually
I'm interested in people who uh want the
job it's it's got some fun parts to
[Music]
it I just want to make certain that they
here that we specifically and formally
thank War Buffett and and Bill Gates for
visiting the University of Washington
business school and please show them
your appreciation as I show them out of
the AR for
[Music]
thanks so what did you think both Bill
and Warren were both very entertaining
and a lot of the questions or on a
personal basis so that was kind of nice
to see another side of them as opposed
to the business side Warren
Buffett's comments about being true to
yourself and following what it is that
feels right bring true to me that was
good to hear that message especially
from someone who's been so incredibly
successful in what he's done both of
them mentioned about like in order to
succeed you must be happy in what you do
and that I find it uh to be much more
important than and uh acquiring wealth
and uh Fame in the sense that uh you
have your internal sense of uh
achievement that you have done something
that is
different Buffett and Gates on success
was made possible by the Floyd and
Dolores Jones Foundation supporting
efforts to enhance public education and
a better understanding of business and
investing in the American economy
[Music]
this program is brought to you by the
NASDAQ stock market timely investment
information is available at nasdaq.com
and
by the New York Stock
Exchange the world puts its stock in
[Music]
US to order video cassettes and the
transcript of buffet and Gates on
success please call kcts at 1 1800
937 5387